we're talking to Miranda in Tennessee
Miranda's two years into her optometrist
degree has two more years to go she and
her boyfriend are planning to get
married
he makes 55 at ups and has his degree
they've got a pile of debt between the
two of them and they're trying to figure
out which one goes first the marriage or
the money or the degrees or all this
stuff
that a fair summary of what you told me
so far yeah all right okay
all right how old are you guys well I'm
23 and he's 24 okay cool so when do you
plan to get married um we're planning to
get married on our 12-year anniversary
which would be September 9th of 2022 why
are you waiting
not enough time uh well we just don't
have any money okay
do you work other than do you work or
you just go to school um so I'm I'm in
two degrees I'm also getting my master's
in business I'm so in total I'm in 28
credit hours but I do tutoring and as
well as some federal work-study but I
make like maybe a hundred 150 a month
nothing okay yeah and so do you you live
at home or you live with him um he moved
with me to Memphis were both from Ohio
originally okay so you the two of you
live together in Memphis yeah and I
realized that you're probably gonna like
this but he is kind of my only source of
income here so I don't have to take out
extra loans to live so I mean we really
would like to be married so we can go
get me yeah yeah I thought about that
but it's just I guess it's the dream
like the normal people dream of a big
wedding and normal people don't move to
Memphis together when they're 23 right
no that's the problem you've made
decisions that have boxed yourself into
this and
you've got you know you've got so many
things on your plate things are falling
off your plate yeah that's why you're
spreading poison keeps rising and I keep
yeah originally they said a hundred
thousand and now I'm probably going to
graduate with 150 plus sure man see you
got you got a limit that that's that's
getting out of control you're gonna get
yourself into a mess here so on right
well the advice I give Miranda on the
show here is and it's just it's been an
easy way for me to control my ethics and
my opinions over the years is if I woke
up in your shoes what would I do
well I turned 60 this year so it's not
relative okay so instead I would say
I've got my youngest child is 28 and
married so if one of my kids or their
friends was sitting at my kitchen table
that I love dearly and told me this
story what I would tell them to do is
get married this weekend and have a
celebration of some kind when you
graduate when you've got some money
mm-hmm
because you've got too many things on
your plate and you are in a very
precarious very dangerous situation you
have no income you're progressively
going deeper into debt so you're 100%
dependent upon him and if you're going
to act like you're married you might as
well be married that's what I would tell
somebody that I love right and you do
what you want to do you called me so I'm
gonna love you and tell you the truth
and what I would do well because I think
it's going to give you an advantage that
the two of you will look at this the the
debt that you both have the future that
you have differently once you're married
but instead you've got like this extra
bill laying out there for this Ken and
Barbie wedding that you used to play
when you were six down ten to ten little
dolls go down the out down tented end
and antonin and you've got that in your
head right and but you make decisions
that did away with that you want
$150,000 in debt and you moved in with a
guy in Memphis and so you've you've made
decisions that it puts you where you are
and
not mad at you I just wouldn't you know
I think you gave up as the fantasy
wedding when you didn't do it in this
order and because you don't have the
money and you're not gonna have the
money for a four years you're right I
mean fifty five thousand is not going to
feed you all and get you guys through
all this stuff and fight the debt that
you both have and pay for a nice wedding
in two years while you go to school it's
just not gonna do it you don't have the
money so you might as well get married
and then let's fight this together and
so then you roll up your sleeves and you
say alright we've got perhaps two
hundred thousand dollars in debt we got
to fight through the good news is you
should make a hundred and he probably
can get his income up towards there as
his career in high tea progresses and if
you get up to making a couple of hundred
a year after you graduate you can clean
up a couple of hundred fairly quickly
but um you know something's gonna go
sideways here and you're gonna have a
problem if you don't because you're just
vulnerable you're in a very dangerous
precarious situation now you do what you
want to do but that's certainly what I
would tell you to do hey thanks for
calling in